hi oh my goodness i have never seen
another person hold my book
until this moment and so i was like oh
my god the first time i'm seeing someone
hold my book it's drew barrymore
oh my gosh i'm not kidding when we first
started this show
and i wanted to describe the
conversations that i wanted to have
i kept talking about you i'm such a long
time fan
and your poetry is so important and
meaningful
and you have hooked so many people with
it with
poetry and i just think that it's so
extraordinary
do you have any objectivity on why what
you put out there resonates so much with
people
you know i think that poetry in general
is the easiest and can at times maybe be
the freest form of therapy a person can
get that day
because for the most part it's a really
emotion focused way of communicating and
there's so many spaces where they tell
us don't bring your emotions you know
don't be emotional i think especially as
women we've cut off so much of ourselves
in order to try to
progress into certain spaces and that's
changing a lot now but i think that
poetry
is always saying like your heart belongs
in this room
your heart belongs in this conversation
your heart belongs in this communication
and so you know i just feel so grateful
that people have allowed
for my poetry to maybe be an entry point
into going into the genre at all i have
so many people who are like i
hated poetry but i loved heart talk or
you know i never thought i'd like it or
get into it and i think that
for me you know whether it's through my
writing for poetry or
activism in any form i'm always just
looking for the easiest
on wrath on-ramp or entry point to get
people involved and in touch with
themselves
well you have a beautiful new daughter
memphis
yes and
you dedicated this book to her and by
the way i love your man
simon um i was lucky enough to work with
him on charlie's angels
um back in the day and now you have this
beautiful
new daughter together memphis who's uh
just turned a year is that correct
yeah she's about a year and two months
so
oh yeah now you wrote this beautiful new
children's book i can't think of a
better pairing than cleo wade and a
children's book it's called what the
road
said um may i ask again
what your light bulb moment was for
creating this book
you know when i first started the
journey of this book it's so
interesting because i really started
writing it i think for my childhood self
i wasn't pregnant
um when i started this book and i really
you know i just remember in my own
childhood just feeling like
there was so many times where i felt so
alone or there were these
really big questions i had and no one
really had the answers to them or i was
even afraid to voice them
and i wondered if there was more out
there i wondered how to use my voice i
wondered how to find
or understand bravery or vulnerability
or all these things that
we still even struggle with as adults
and so i wanted to write something that
was
like a healing bomb to my childhood self
and then halfway through the process
i got pregnant and it was so crazy
because this
journey that started for my own
childhood healing
ended up becoming a book for my daughter
um and so the this book is so personal
and so
um emotional for me i i seriously still
i've been started doing interviews about
it like
two weeks ago and i almost cry every
time because
you know it really is um it's everything
you know it's every thing i hope
my daughter can know in her life um and
it's everything i hope that every
young girl or young person um you know
it's it's something i wish they could
all have
truly um i'm so proud of this and so
uh it's a really emotional book for me
um but i'm so excited to put it put it
out
well i'm sure your daughter will marvel
with parents like you and simon and
i think that we're all looking for the
takeaways in life it's so
important and your work is so full of
them
thank you so much um i'm i'm
i just can't even believe you just said
that to me so thank you so much
thank you so much cleo wade for coming
here to talk about your children's book
which i
again was like oh that's the most potent
combination
um what the road said is available now
in stores and online wherever books are
sold
thank you so much say hi to simon
and hello to beautiful memphis
you